frau weigel erste hochrechnung ist
heraus ganz genau weiß man es natürlich
um diese uhrzeit noch nicht aber klar
ist die afg hat ein - hier in baden
württemberg stehen wie zufrieden sind
sie dann mit dem ergebnis
ich bin mit dem ergebnis sehr zufrieden
und möchte mich auch zuerst meinen
wählern bedanken die uns gewählt haben
und auch bei unseren vielen
ehrenamtlichen mitgliedern die trotz
widriger bedingungen so einen guten
wahlkampf hingelegt haben wir mit
repressalien zu rechnen auch tätliche
angriffe dann wurde der
verfassungsschutz gegen uns in stellung
gebracht so wirklich anteil wochen vor
den landtagswahlen völlig rechtswidrig
und dementsprechend sind wir sehr
zufrieden so ein solides ergebnis
eingefahren zu haben wie ich da jetzt
nach der ersten hochrechnungen zwischen
11,8 und 12 5 prozent
das ist mehr als wir gerechnet haben und
ich glaube auch noch da ist noch luft
nach oben und damit können wir sehr
zufrieden sein dennoch ein - sie haben
gerade ein paar gründe gesagt genannt
die aus ihrer sicht eine rolle gespielt
haben aber welchen anteil hat die baden
württemberger afd daran dass hier ein
minus steht
na gut das ist ja jetzt die zweite
legislatur wir haben die ersten
legislatur hinter uns gebracht und es
ist ja auch kein geheimnis dass die
fraktionen zu beginnen jetzt kein gutes
bild abgegeben hat wir haben da eine
fraktion spaltung gehabt und und und wir
waren ja konsolidierungsphase und das
ist natürlich jetzt nicht mehr der erste
einzug sondern das verlorene vertrauen
musste auch wieder aufgebaut werden und
das hat der landesverband auch die
fraktionen sehr sehr gut hinbekommen
sie sind jetzt landesvorsitzende in
baden württemberg
der fraktionsvorsitzende hat
ein bisschen ernüchternd gesagt über
seine letzten jahre ihm sei es nicht
gelungen die unterschiedlichen flügel
der partei in baden württemberg zusammen
zu bringen was wollen sie jetzt besser
machen also unser ziel ist in der tat
wirklich auch das gesamte spektrum auch
mit abzubilden
die leute aus den verschiedenen flügeln
mitzunehmen und das gelingt bei den
einmal besser aber in anderen
schlächtern aber das ist bei den anderen
parteien auch so und sie haben den
anspruch dass zusammen zu bringen oder
in welche richtung möchten sie die
partei hier in baden württemberg für ja
in erster linie professionalisierung die
professionalisierung und die
disziplinierung steht hier im
vordergrund und völlig anders auch
aufzustellen
wir sind ja auch nach geschäftsfeldern
auch aufgeteilt und dummerweise müssen
wir sagen dass wir jetzt durch die
korona bedingungen
dadurch dass wir auch mitglieder
parteitage eben haben bei uns sind die
parteitage sehr groß als dieser
landesvorstand gewählt wurde war hatten
wir in der spitze 1200 mitglieder in
einer halle und durch diese ganzen chor
ohne bedingungen auch durch die
versammlungsverbote können wir natürlich
nicht zusammentreten und das erschwert
manchmal auch die arbeit auch die
kommunikation unter den mitgliedern
aber da versuchen wir natürlich
bestmöglich auch weiterhin zu
kommunizieren und mit den leuten
zusammen zu kommen aber es ist natürlich
so dass corona die zusammenarbeit nicht
einfacher gemacht hat eben war der
spitzenkandidat bernd göbel bei uns hier
bei phoenix beim am set und mich hat es
ein bisschen überrascht dass er gesagt
hat er müsste morgen mal gucken ob er
weiter fraktionsvorsitzender bleibt
warum stellt das in frage stellen dies
infrage dass bei google weiter
fraktionsvorsitzender bleibt also ich
hoffe dass sie ihnen gefragt haben wie
er das gemeint hat also ich hab nur eine
interpretation
also erstens hat bernd göbel
einen guten job gemacht als
spitzenkandidat und er weiß natürlich
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht und ich
auch nicht wie sich die zukünftige
fraktionen zusammensetzen denn wir haben
diese sehr spezielle wahlrecht in baden
württemberg das geht ja relativ nach den
ergebnissen und dementsprechend muss man
sich die wahlkreis ergebnisse anschauen
welcher kandidat überhaupt einzieht und
da setzt sich daneben die neue fraktion
zusammen das kann man heute abend noch
nicht sagen alles bei der herzlichen
dank dankeschön